ok donc c'est une prof qui est en classe
et qui dit bon alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire plus tard et là elle dit à
l'épaule vas-y et là il dit alors moi
plus tard je veux un yacht je veux une
villa de ouf je veux une biade sur le
yacht je veux de l'argent à gogo je vais
pouvoir l'acheter tout ce que je veux
franchement je me fous l'oseille et
vraiment je veux une belle bonne bière
sur l'opération le bateau la preuve
on va on va descendre deux trois tombes
on va aller sur quelqu'un un peu plus
sage Marie tu veux faire quoi bah moi
j'ai changé d'avis je vais te la biatch
de Paul du coup
c'est un garçon qui est avec son père et
elle disait
[Applaudissements]
moi si j'étais et donc du coup il dit
arrête je vais rougir non et il dit papa
c'est quoi un homme alors il dit bah mon
fils un homme c'est quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de la maison qui sécurise qui
s'occupe bien de ses enfants qui fait
attention qu'il y ait de l'argent qui
rentre dans le foyer qui vraiment
s'occupe que tout soit bien à la maison
et tout en ordre ah d'accord alors papa
c'est bon je sais ce que je vais faire
plus tard moi aussi je vais être un
homme comme maman
[Applaudissements]
qui dit maman c'est quoi la fait que
tout le monde déteste c'est la fécara
bosse elle dit maman toi c'est quoi la
fée qui te ressemble le plus c'est la
finante elle dit et papa c'est quoi la
fée qu'il aime le plus c'est la
fellation
bien bien
Jean-Marie tu vois Jean-Marie